[Música]
ah
importantes medidas de seguridad
sanitaria enmarcan las celebraciones de
semana santa este año en el vaticano
para evitar el riesgo del contagio el
rito del lava miento de los pies ha sido
cancelado este jueves santo el papá
francisco celebró la misa del crisma en
la basílica de san pedro con una
presencia muy reducida de fieles y
concelebrantes durante su homilía el
papa evocó la fragilidad de la condición
humana y exhortó a los fieles católicos
a vivir esta semana santa a través de la
reflexión y de la oración el viernes
santo el vía crucis no se llevará a cabo
en el coliseo romano como era el caso
antes de la pandemia sino en la plaza de
san pedro' vacías infieles y el domingo
el papa no se asomará al balcón de la
basílica de san pedro para pronunciar su
tradicional bendición urbi et orbi este
domingo la bendición será transmitida en
directo desde el interior del vaticano
por segundo año consecutivo las
celebraciones de semana santa en mexico
se llevan a cabo de manera virtual para
evitar más contagios de kobe 19 por
ejemplo la representación teatral de la
pasión de cristo' que año con año se
realiza en la iglesia de la pruebita en
iztapalapa en la ciudad de mexico y que
ha llegado a congregar a más de millón y
medio de personas en esta ocasión
también será a puerta cerrada y con un
número reducido de actores en escena
será transmitida por redes sociales y
por distintos canales de televisión
públicos y privados para que los fieles
puedan seguir esta tradición a distancia
la iglesia católica ha dicho que si bien
las parroquias permanecerán abiertas el
aforo será reducido de acuerdo con lo
permitido por las autoridades sanitarias
en el país y hace un llamado a los
feligreses a seguir las misas vía
televisión así como las conmemoraciones
del sábado de gloria y domingo de
resurrección
[Música]
es una semana santa en una situación de
crisis sanitaria y de inseguridad
generalizada aquí en haití como lo dicta
la tradición los católicos se están
preparando para marcar esta semana hoy
en la mañana esta misa crismal donde los
obispos y los sacerdotes están reuniendo
para bendecir el aceite de defunción
mañana tendrá lugar la posición cada año
son más de 300 personas que caminan en
la calle para marcar este día no podemos
esperar tanta gente en las calles este
año por la situación de inseguridad
generalizada
podemos observar algunos cambios en las
prácticas religiosas ciertas actividades
tienen lugar virtualmente lo seguro es
que los cristianos son muy motivados
porque están celebrando dos eventos
importantes en su vida espiritual la
muerte del cristo y su resurrección
porque según ellos dicen siempre esta
semana más importante en su vida
[Música]